in this video on a wrap-up the electron
transport chain by talking about
oxidative phosphorylation chemiosmosis
and ATP synthase and sort of drawing out
the complexes themselves now what is
oxidative phosphorylation just as a sort
of definition it's basically using redox
reactions to power the phosphorylation
of adp into ATP and how do we actually
do that we do it via establishing what
we we mentioned earlier an electro
chemical gradient right specifically a
pH gradient right with the H pluses now
the reason it's called an
electrochemical gradient is because a
chemical gradient just describes the
idea that have if you have a membrane
and you have more of one thing on one
side than the other then you have a
chemical gradient but now in the case of
H pluses right those are protons are
charged they have a positive charge so
there's an electrical gradient as well
which is described as a voltage as the
difference in charge as a charge
separation so that's another basically
sort of aspect of the gradient itself
another this idea of chemiosmosis
chemiosmosis is basically the movement
of ions down their concentration
gradient through a selectively permeable
membrane so in this case what are we
thinking about for that ion or thinking
about H plusses ATP synthase what is ATP
synthase it's the protein that makes ATP
so it's going to be a pretty cool
protein okay now what does the electron
transport chain kind of look like let's
kind of think about it like this so we
have excuse me we have four different
protein complexes we have complex number
one we have complex number two we have
complex number three here and then we
have complex number four down here so
you have four protein complexes and then
over here at the end we got good old ATP
synthase so we're going to see how how
this is
how that have this electron transport
chain actually works so if this is the
outer mitochondrial membrane here and
this is the inner mitochondrial membrane
then the electron transport chain is
along this inner mitochondrial membrane
is approaching complexes along the
membrane so anything inside here is
considered the matrix anything out here
would be part of the inter membrane
space so if we think about this what's
what's happening here so initially we
said we had NADH come to complex number
one and then it's reoxidized back into
nad plus and then complex one we said
pumps protons and it does now in in you
know biochemistry books you'll probably
see that complex one will pump four
protons so for every two electrons you
get four protons pumped into the
intermembrane space so these protons are
building up over here in the
intermembrane space and these protons
are coming from the matrix out into the
intermembrane space now what is this
blue line I've drawn here I've drawn a
bunch of different blue lines it kind of
looks like a mess but if you see a blue
line a blue line is electron flow so
this here is electrons flowing here
these electrons are flowing here any
blue lines you see those are electrons
flowing which is the purpose of the
electron transport chain any pink lines
you'll see that describes proton
movement or flow okay now in this case
it's against the gradient right so at
complex one we know that NADH is
oxidized back in eighty plus and we have
proton pumping so that's what's
happening at complex number one and in
addition these electrons are flowing
from complex one over to complex
actually they don't float a complex two
they flow over to this Q thing here
which is coenzyme q so
the excuse me the complex number two
where we turn succinate into fumarate on
the matrix side of the mitochondria or
the major side of the inner membrane
this occurs at complex number two and
the electrons flow to collect coenzyme q
but notice that I have not drawn a pink
line here going into the intermembrane
space because this complex does not pump
protons then once we have cones I'm Q
the electrons from coenzyme q go over to
complex number three and then to
cytochrome C and notice complex number
three actually pumps protons as well it
pumps four protons as well so we have
four protons they're being pumped into
the intermembrane space cytochrome C
then gives its electrons to cytochrome a
cytochrome a gives it two which is I
mean which is part of complex four which
gives us electrons to oxygen which
becomes water so we're going here from
oxygen we're starting off with 1/2
oxygen and we also add if this 1/2 of o2
is just an O right so if that's how we
get this open in water so we must have
added two protons in addition to two
electrons that are coming from here so
basically in addition this complex
number for which I almost forgot also
pumps protons but in this case it
actually only pumps two protons why that
is I'm not entirely sure I actually even
just read an article recently about how
maybe complex one doesn't actually pump
four protons it might only pump three so
I think these numbers sometimes still
might be you know biochemists are still
trying to figure them out I'm not really
totally sure about that but in anyway
the point is that they all do contribute
to the proton gradient except complex
number two so notice that we're building
up a proton gradient here both by
pumping protons through these three
complexes but in addition to that we're
also were race
we were increasing the H+ concentration
in the intermembrane space with all our
previous IMS and we're decreasing the H+
concentration in the matrix well how are
we doing that well first of all we're
taking the protein the protons out of
the matrix right to dump them into the
intermembrane space so that's one thing
but another thing is that these protons
here right are being picked up to make
water so this also lowers the H+
concentration right in the matrix which
can also contribute to further
establishing them the the concentration
gradient right so this this this makes
the matrix less concentrated while these
three make make the the intermembrane
space more concentrated specifically by
pumping the protons over there so what
do we end up having what well we already
mentioned that we have all these
different protons now in the in the
intermembrane space and very little out
here in the matrix so what's going on we
have here you'll notice that I put these
little plus plus charges or plus signs
along the membrane of the entice word
along the inter membrane space side of
the inner mitochondrial membrane because
of all these protons here we build up a
base relatively positive charge it's
relatively positive compared to the
inside here the matrix where we have
these negative charges because there's
more positively charged molecules or
more positively charged species with the
protons on the intermembrane space side
than there are in the matrix so now all
these these protons they want to come
back in right these these protons want
to come back in they're just waiting for
their opportunity to you know to come
back in they can only come back in
through ATP synthase now ATP synthase is
a has has an f0 region and an f1 region
the FO region is basically the the
proton Channel that's what allows the
protons to flow through and then the f1
portion is actually the ATP synthase
portion that's the portion that actually
makes the ATP so basically what ATP
synthase does is it allow
it allows these protons right to flow
through this channel here back into the
matrix down their concentration gradient
and when that happens that is a
spontaneous process so that spontaneous
process powers the production of ATP
from ADP and phosphate groups so we're
making ATP here so you can see now why
establishing this proton gradient was
important we needed this gradient to to
be formed so that they can spontaneously
come back down the gradient through ATP
synthase and ATP synthase harnesses that
energy to power the production of ATP so
that's essentially what's going on with
the electron transport chain that's how
we we make our energy because basically
we went from we bent went from let me
write this up here we went from nadh and
fadh2 right which were you know stored
reduced energy forms and then what we
did was we we took that went through
redox reactions right and those redox
reactions were exergonic right and they
they powered the establishing of this
electrochemical gradient right so
electrochemical gradient I'm losing
space here the electrochemical gradient
and that electrochemical gradient right
all of these basically stored energy
here this is you know free energy that's
being released in these redox reactions
that power is the production of this
electrochemical gradient all these
energies they're stored energies but we
can't use those energies those are not
the energy currencies that we use we use
ATP as energy so basically what we did
was we took the energy from these
different forms took this
electrochemical gradient and used it to
make a usable oops
usable chemical energy right which in
our case is ATP it's pretty Knology if
you ask me I'm that's awesome so I hope
that was helpful that cleared things up
thanks for watching